I'm not saying they shouldn't have
consequences but these laws often reach
down to a child of age six five I mean
it's incredible hi I'm Tracy Oppenheimer
Friesen TV today we're speaking with
Susan IVA Porter author of the new book
bully nation askew thanks for talking to
us thank you so everyone from
politicians to celebrities and pop stars
seems to have bullying on the brain
today
why have we entered this age of a bully
nation kids are no different than they
used to be but something has changed and
as an educator working in schools I
noticed over the last decade there
really has been a shift in how we think
about kids parents educators legislators
we're the ones who are really scripting
this idea of what childhood looks like
now and people are terrified stems
some studies show that the thing that
terrifies parents most at the beginning
of the school year is that their child
will be bullied in school and one of the
reasons they're terrified is that this
language is inflammatory you call a
child a bully and you're turning the
heat up you call a child well you know
what that kid misbehaved that doesn't
turn the heat up and so what we have
especially in the media but it seeped
into parent conversations educator
conversations conversations between kids
we have this very inflamed rhetoric that
then puts people at great disease and
really I think diverts them from
solutions you said kids aren't the ones
who have changed so why is it getting so
much more attention now because I think
we live in a constant state of fear in
this country I believe one of the events
that caused this shift was Columbine one
of the things that made Columbine so
horrifying besides the fact that it was
an inherently horrifying event is that
it played out live on television after
the event came to a conclusion people
were asking the question why did this
happen and one of the answers that was
the easiest answer and it was the answer
that people really glommed onto
especially the media was that the two
boys responsible for the massacre
been bullied well in fact I hadn't but
that became a very easy way of
understanding the horror so then we
started to pair what was happening in
schools with these really really
dreadful outcomes and created a
conceptual framework around it there are
bullies that there are victims that you
can be an ally or you're a bystander
once this framework was created and
labeling the bullies and the victims
what were some of the policies and media
attention that that's been particularly
detrimental I think one of the most
detrimental things we can do to a child
is give them a label we no longer call
children stupid for instance if they
feel a math test
we don't say hey you're a [ __ ] we
would never in a million years say that
if we wanted to help the child and we
understand that were we to do that not
only is the negativity damaging but when
a child sees themselves as only one
thing which is what a label encourages
them to do it stops them thinking about
their potential their growth how they
can change so once we start labeling
kids bully victim Ally bystander we've
created this this sort of fixed scenario
or this fixed play that they're in and
they lose perspective about who they are
as people but also they don't have any
incentive to change because we've just
said to them this is who you are that I
think is the biggest most damaging thing
we've done the other thing we've started
to do is create a lot of anti-bullying
legislation so we're now legislating
childhood and a lot of this legislation
has language around it like
zero-tolerance well we're talking about
zero-tolerance for kids making mistakes
so if we take away bully language and we
say well that kid isn't a bully that
kids that that kid is somebody who's
made a mistake that kid is somebody who
hasn't learned a lesson yet but the way
we're gonna try and make them learn it
is is calm down so hard and so
emphatically that we're gonna have a law
mmm-hmm against what they do again I'm
not saying they shouldn't have
consequences but these laws often reach
to a child of age six five I mean it's
incredible and so we're now trying to
mediate problems in childhood through a
legislative response and another aspect
of zero tolerance and a lot of
legislation is either it's typically
one-size-fits-all absolutely so how do
we approach this from a more case based
basis we've got to take a comprehensive
approach and zero tolerance isn't
comprehensive at all we want them to be
invested in change we want their parents
to be invested in change parents are the
people most invested in helping a child
you call a child bully and you lose
their parent because they're offended
they're defensive okay so we want to
help it kid change and if we say to them
you can never do that again you can
never make that mistake again if you do
the world will collapse which is really
the zero tolerance approach where is
that kid to go when they don't meet our
expectations that's when they need us
they don't need us when we're good yeah
you're good yeah they need us when
they're bad they need us when they make
mistakes
and we call them bullies we are no
longer invested in helping them by
inserting this language in these
techniques are we actually making the
bullying problem worse Oh becoming more
aggressive because of it they're
becoming less resilient if you're now a
victim and you think of yourself as a
victim you are much more apt to get
victimized and now we're not teaching
kids you know sometimes you just I know
you're feeling bad and let's help you
get over your feelings but this
situation is going to go away if you
deal with your feelings and recognize
that feelings come and go and your
experience with that doesn't mean that's
who you are I'm glad I'm not in middle
school today so am I let me tell you
know thanks for talking to us again my
pleasure
freezin TV I'm Tracy Oppenheimer
you